I'm a big ice-cream guy I got a cone
every night every night yeah what's up
everybody welcome to stupid questions
with Krista Stefano I'm Krista Stefano
this is Marc Norman you can check out
his website Marc Norman comedy calm or
watch it special don't be yourself on
Comedy Central calm listen to his
podcast Tuesdays with stories nailed
there nailed that I got a lot of it you
know more than my parents
you're a Pope for the day oh wow what
would you now make a sin what would you
decree as it's in probably DJing yeah
yeah rid of DJing that just bothers me
yeah this guy sucks yeah they make so
much money I know someone who makes
compañero something forty-five million a
year what the DJ what is that I don't
know it's not an instrument one time I
saw a DJ using his equipment on top of a
grand piano yeah which is like that's
like banging a blow-up doll on top of an
actual woman come on what do you think's
the absolute worst name you can name a
kid what's it just a rap dumb name
uh what's a bad name I guess hemorrhoid
Johnson yeah this is a true person that
existed that I knew okay her last name
was jar okay
her first name was pickle come on not
lying to you Wow I know a girl in my
middle school SH and uh last name leer
yeah yeah leer there you go stripper now
group names
alright next stupid question we're both
stand-up comics here's what's your a
best bombing story or worst one time I
did a gig at the Comedy Cellar went
pretty well so this guy said hey I work
at a hedge fund
I wait to come roast my company so he
gave me a whole rap sheet of all his
employees and it was heavy stuff he's
like be vicious be brutal really kill
him and I was like alright you got it
get in there white tablecloth
everybody's looks well-to-do rich and he
goes alright there's your podium you got
your list like I got it all and I just
go into it I go Bob we all know you're
cheating on your wife and she's there
she's like what that didn't go well so I
move on I go hey Jim we all know you're
addicted to coke and his sponsors
they're like what the hell would he
crazy you lied to me yeah you know so he
leaves and then I go hey Jeff we all
know you're gay his kids are there
they're like I do it and they all run
out and I'm bombing horrible and I do
like five more those none of them work
get offstage and the guys like what the
hell was that what was that it was crazy
I was like I just used the stuff you
gave me he's like you blew it you blew
it night and it got no money next stupid
question hmm what would be the worst buy
one get one free sale of all time
Wow I one get one free what do you
thinks the worst probably prostitute
because you have sex one prostate you
feel the shame you don't even want the
other one yeah you're finished you're
like wow this was a big mistake on -
it's like when you go to the grocery
store hungry yeah I was too horny I was
I was thinking with my dick so my eyes
are bigger than my dick there was a guy
in Vegas I saw he was like walked out
he goes what corner are the toots
on the news on prostitutes - he was like
what corner the topes on I was like I
don't know like oh look a guy loads of
prizes like where the toads all right
you have a good time here any questions
this is what I do great dude love it
you're a good host I got you guys I got
you a gift so I'm honored I can't
believe it so I know you know you're
from New Orleans yeah
I got you these get out these are crab
claws look at that
I love it well that was good right yeah
this is great thank you stupid questions
of Christa Stafford arm Christa Stefano
this is mark Normand check him out mark
Normand comedy comm tuesdays with
stories and a special don't be yourself
[Music]